[MUSIC PLAYING]
UTTAM KUMAR TRIPATHI:
Google Developer Groups
is a global program active
in over 130 countries.
These committees work with
hundreds and thousands
of developers in
over 130 countries,
working on activities and
events like Dev Fest, Study Jam,
hackathons, code labs.
It's a great challenge
and avenue for you
if you want to have access
to innovators and makers.
[CHEERING]
RALPH VINCENT REGALADO: What
drives me to be a community
organizer is really
to help developers
be better developers.
We want to create an avenue
for them to learn new skills.
We want them to collaborate
with other developers.
RAYAN AL ZAHAB: We
have a lot of events
in which we get the
trainings on technical stuff
and even on life
experience stuff.
NITYA NARASIMHAN:
What the community
does is it doesn't matter
where you're from, your gender,
ethnicity, none of it.
You walk in the door.
You find someone like
you, and you connect.
KATE HENDERSON: It's
just access to resources.
And it is the
like-minded people,
where you feel so much more
motivated and so much more
encouraged if you can
talk to people like that.
DIEGO DE GRANDA: What
we are trying to do
is to create more like
content, documentation,
code labs, videos about
different technologies.
SUYASH DIXIT: Our committee
focuses on local people,
local developers.
But bringing the more diverse
ideas from all around the globe
can help us reshape our
vision for the better way.
SAM RAMJI:
Communities are places
where people find meaning,
where they find support,
where they find the real value
in using any kind of tools.
NITYA NARASIMHAN:
What Google has
done in helping GDG's growth
is basically giving them
the umbrella of here are things
that could help you coordinate.
But they don't necessarily
try to tell us what to do.
ROINA OCHIENG: We
do have resources
that are facilitated by Google.
And what we try to do as
communities is make sure
that the content is relevant
to our individual communities.
JENNIFER KOHL: If you
want to join a GDG,
you can find us at
developers.google.com/groups.
You can join thousands of
developers around the world
just like you, doing
really amazing things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]